kale marar k SMI winner Stanley Cup
winner already Norris seriously he
is on a ridiculous Ascent step
shoot scores kale has his first
in the up it's transformed the franchise Nate
McKinnon Landis SC ranton all those guys said
it it's just changed everything for us it all
started with kale reded with an assist audio goal
250 career points now for T Mar the fastest
in terms of games from a defenseman in NHL
history back
the darting him with the back
hit John SC kale the car that
was an absolute thing of [Music]
beauty what pishing by K M getting
[Applause]
over deliv off to talk back
to kale holds shoot and scores
the [Music]
longer
score call St to shoots and scores to and on
those three Avalanche goals K Mar you've got
a help for every single one his third consecutive
game with three assists you look in any CH history
Cy g b Kim mcard just continuing to hang with
Elite company while we talk about hockey IQ and
this is putting it on the Einstein level
what a career he's off to a Norris Trophy
already a con Smite just a brilliant player
the best defenseman in the National Hockey
League